we begin in Sudan where there's heavy
fighting between the Army and
paramilitary Rapid support forces the
battle between the two has intensified
in southern Khartoum where rapid support
forces claimed to be inside a weapons
Factory in the area of yarmukh let's go
live to Heber Morgan who joins us now
from ondaman can you just bring us up to
date with the latest exactly where this
huge fire has broken out
well the fire broke out at a warehouse
near a weapons manufacturing company
that belongs to the Sudanese armed
forces in the southern part of the
capital Khartoum that's where there's
been intense fighting on Tuesday and the
fighting that continued in the early
hours of Wednesday and still continues
at this moment the rapid support forces
claims that it is now in control of that
weapons Manufacturing Company the
biggest in the country that manufactures
all the weapons for the Sudanese Armed
Forces we spoke to Army sources and
asked them what the situation was on the
ground and they say that fighting is
still very much ongoing residents say
that they can hear loud explosions they
can hear Heavy Artillery around the
areas near the factory that manufactures
the weapons for the Sudanese army they
also say that they can hear the fighter
jets flying overhead and that there's
been airstrikes launched around that
area so fighting is still ongoing the
rapid support forces say that they are
in control of that manufacturing company
but people are are really concerned
because again this is a weapons
Manufacturing Company any kind of
activity especially fighting around it
and it lies in the middle of a
residential area residents will be
caught up in the middle in this fighting
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army as they try to gain
control of this manufacturing company
we've just been watching some of the
live pictures of this fire really is
huge can you just tell us a little bit
about the impact that it could
potentially have on the civilians that
that are still nearby
well it's a warehouse
contains few
and it's
at Jason's manufacturing company people
who live in that area who we spoke to
say that there's been loud explosions
about two hours ago that the area around
the warehouse and the company is now out
of power and that there's no water and
their concerns because there are fuel in
that area because there's gas in that
area that is resulting in this fire and
uh to to continue for the past few hours
and because it's near a weapons Factory
there are concerns that there will be
large explosions now many people who
spoke to say that they've already left
the area because they're concerned about
what might happen about a potential
explosion uh at the warehouse at the
company that could lead to a massive
destruction in the southern part of the
capital but there are residents who say
they cannot leave they say that they've
got uh older elderly people behind that
living with them that they can't leave
behind they say that the situation is
very hard at the moment it's quite hot
because of the flames and the heat that
is coming out of the fire they say that
they're unable to move and there's no
water civil defense Services which are
usually can and deploy firefighters is
not working because of the ongoing
fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army so there
are concerns that in the next few hours
if the fire is not contained it will
eventually engulf residential homes in
the area and should it reach the weapons
Manufacturing Company there will be a
major explosion that could destroy
hundreds and hundreds of homes in the
southern parts of the capital okay let's
hope it doesn't come to that thank you
so much that has ever Morgan for us in
umdaman